this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you Larry yeah and thank
you all for uh attending my ex seminar
uh so here's a quick uh overview of what
I'm going to cover in this presentation
so we'll start off with a quick
background on sex termination and the
salad KC family which is what includes
the Willows and the poplars then we'll
move into uh how we try to understand
the genetic mechanisms of sex
determination in trouble though so we
started with this sort of Integrative
genomics and bioinformatics approach to
identify candidate sex determination
genes we then refine some of those
hypotheses using monisha's Willows and
families to be generated from those and
then we functionally validated our
Canada genes through overexpression and
arabidopsis and dapsy and honestly I'll
finish off by talking about a couple
other projects that I've worked on one
involving the Genova assembly annotation
of 11 stroke genomes and another on how
we developed a protoplast transient
expression and knockout assay to enable
future functional genomic studies in
struggling
so a quick background on uh Willow so
Willers are the genus Salix these are
over 300 species these included the tree
Willows which you buy me most familiar
with uh that you see around in parks and
Gardens also the shrug Willows and the
Arctic Wolf brothers now in the Smart
Lab we are primarily in the breeding and
genetics of shrub Wells for biomass and
bioenergy production so in a bio energy
production they're grown in high density
plantings shown here and they're
accomplished every two to four years and
these wood chips are then used are
burned to generate heat and electricity
however struggles also have several
other applications so they're used as
ornamentals uh also you need to logical
restoration and then in some traditional
uses like basket
so one key feature of the Willows are
that they are daishes they have separate
male and female plants and that's
primarily where my research comes in so
uh here so here are the the female cat
can see here on the left and these are
the male catkins on the right so cat can
just refer to this whole inflorescence
here
and my research specifically focuses on
the species cynics papyria as a model
for the shrub Willows and uh which had a
chromosome 15 ZW sex germination system
so all that means is that chromosome 15
is a sex chromosome and they the females
are ZW and the males are as easy so the
W's only inheritance to 13 mli notably
rules are also the sister genus of the
poplars or populists so popular Striker
carpet is the model tree so it can
leverage some of the genomic resources
available from that in our study of
realism now getting into sex
determination and sex chromosomes which
is where my research focuses sex
chromosomes are characterized by these
large and non-recombining equations so
uh and these are called sex
determination regions or Str so I'll say
Str and it's talking and that's random
franchise that that large region that we
don't see in combination and one of the
challenges is the sex termination region
can contain hundreds of genes in the
case of settings for hernia there are
488 annotated genes on the chromosome
15w sgr now adjacent to the the Str are
pseudo-adosonal regions regions which
are freely recombining regions of the
sex chromosomes that can be treated like
on those for all intents and purposes
and then when when we look at
inheritance of sex there's two primary
systems in Angeles response here's the X
Y and the zingw and an XY system uh the
males are the heterogeneous sex so males
are X5 and females other homogeneous
exact so females are XX this is the
system that's present in humans and
mammals uh so you're probably humiliated
with that uh ZW on the other hand just
means that males are as easy and females
females so the Japanese only inheritance
into female
box is a system that's present
s so then when we think about how sex is
controlled as far as genes and
mechanistically there are two lead
models the single Gene and the two Gene
model
um and this basically means that only
one or two genes are both necessary and
sufficient to switch sex from one to the
other so there's uh I pictured here a
couple examples of the single Gene and
two Gene systems right so a good example
of the two Gene system is asparagus
where females are xx and this results in
female floral development
on males which are X Y on the Y
chromosome they have this tabidium
development function one gene that
promotes male floral development and the
link to that they have a suppressor of
female function Gene that suppresses
female phone development so you get nail
flowers
an example of a single Gene system is is
persimmon and that's actually kind of a
really interesting system so females are
xx and then there's this autosomal Gene
called Negi and Maggie promotes a
gynoysium development which results in
female flowers Maggie also uh promotes
SVP expression which suppresses
pistolata and because the suppresses
puts a lot and you don't get male full
development so you get female flowers
males have this yochromosome which has
an ogi which is actually a small RNA and
the small RNA is the only Gene that's
necessary to switch Sexes so it does
that by methylating the promoter of
Maggie therefore turning off the
expression of Maggie as a result we
don't get expression of gynoysium but
you do get expression epistle on it and
you get angioethium and nail
so when we're thinking about how do we
understand secretary Nation genes in
struggle though you know we have this
challenge of
almost 500 genes in this extermination
region that are fully linked so we don't
have recombination you know that's you
know as plant meters you know we really
leverage uh recombination so how do we
how do we parse out those almost 500
genes to find the one or two that are
responsible for sex determination
and that's really what my dissertation
is focused on
so now we get a sex determination and
solid Casey family so the solid Casey
family includes uh the populars or
populists and Willow statements and I
have this phylogenetic tree here this
was generated by one of our
collaborators at Texas Tech just to show
you some of the relationship between the
some of the popular species and some of
the same expenses and section V tricks
here highlighted in red these are the
struggles that we use in our reading
and that's our settings Mercury is
so what's interesting is that this
entire family is diocese
however the sex determination region has
actually shifted both heterogeneity
systems and chromosomes
um in this family so in poplars there's
chromosome 19xy chromosome 19 ZW and
chromosome 14 XY systems
and Willows on the other hand so in the
tree Willows chromosome 7 XY is the the
system and some of the basal struggles
it's actually a chromosome 15xy and then
in the the struggles or Matrix and the
dwarfoilers commit uh all these it's
chromosome 15 and ZW
so we can see this system has has
changed multiple times so notably in
popular ar-17 has been implicated as the
single Gene Master regulator of sex
throughout this genus such that its
presence and expression results in
female and a lack of expression either
through its absence or through its
silencing results in male salt at all
so and this appears to be concerned
across populace however we're really
interested in trying to see is this Gene
also involved in Willow is it not how is
the system different will it because
clearly this sex extermination system
has changed multiple times and so we
really want to characterize that further
in the Willows and specifically in the
struggle books
so to start off you know our first step
was to try to get a big picture of what
does sex dimorphism look like in
troubleless so what we did we took this
what we're calling an integrative
genomics approach we took 90 male and 90
female captions after two family we did
GDs receivements on every individual we
also did rnac on each one of those
captains and then small rnac and
bisulfite sequencies look at cpg
methylation on a substantive was as well
and so we you know obtained all this
data and that's actually summarized in
the circle spot here and there's a lot
going on here and you definitely can't
see all of it but I just you know want
to give you a big picture of sort of the
depth of data we've collected and one
could really spend a better part of our
career parsing through all the data from
this but of course we're really
interested in sex determination
so because we collected both genotype
data and expression data we were able to
do an eqtl analysis which is where you
associate expression of genes with
polymorphisms and elsewhere in the
genome
so in this Focus plot here this outer
track these are the relative numbers of
eqtls per Locus in uh from our study and
then in this Inner Circle here in
turquoise I have the the
genes that have eqtl mapping back to the
15wstr and in Gray the genius eqtl
mapping back to the 15z Str so you can
see there are thousands of genes whose
expression is associated with geotypic
polymorphisms in the sex determination
region
this middle track here shows the total
differenti Express genes so we detected
over 24 000 differentiate Express genes
between male and female cats this is not
entirely surprising given the
morphological differences that we
observed between catkins
uh and then this inner track here
these are the differentiating methylated
regions so we detected this is CBG
methylation which we detected using by
sulfide sequence
um so once again blue for male magenta
for female and then those in yellow here
are actually differentially about the
lady regions in the community promoter
regions of genes so one really
interesting finding from this was we saw
about three equal higher methylation in
Dale cat codes relative to female
captions which was very interesting
and then we also did small RNA
sequencies we detected 45 micrornas of
these five actually are unique they
don't they haven't been identified in
any other species and then I have their
top 10 uh Target sites in purple here so
a lot of data from this another key
finding we found was that among these
eqtos so these genes that had
associations back to the Str we
identified 97 transcription factors and
we were really interested in these
because children factors control the
expression of many other genes and these
could represent sort of intermediate
pathway genes between the one or two sex
extermination genes and the 24 000
differential Expressions by controlling
their expression so we wanted to look at
some of those
we also looked at at sex dimorphism
related genes and their associations
through eqtl with tsdr so primarily
floral development genes which are
involved in male or female flower
development and thus primary
sexomorphism and also secondary
metabolism genes so things like
terpenoid flavonoid infinite leukocyte
are these have all compounds have all
been shown to be differentially produced
between male and female academics so we
found that many mass blockchains as well
as these uh secondary compound genes how
do you curtails with the SDR and this
was even after we accounted for sex as a
covariant character statistical analysis
uh this figure here this shows the
flowering pathway genes that are have
been characterized in arabidopsis I have
the the number of parallel or number of
homologs in the willow genome for each
of these genes and then they're purple
if they're there are copies that are
male and female differentially expressed
blue if they're a male and red is their
female differentiate Express so you can
see what differential expression looks
like in the male and female floor
development
and then those highlighted in red here
actually have eqtl uh mapping back to
the sdrs they represent potential
regulatory entry points for the sex
determination region into the floral
development
and then of course we use this genomic
study to identify candidate genes for
sex determination genes we think might
be even masturbating in their genes for
sex so we looked at genes that were
present in the chromosome fiction wsdr
so present in females and absent for
males those that had very high levels of
expression in females those that were we
also did network analysis we identified
genes that were in the female correlated
Network and then lastly we looked at
their functional annotations you think
could potentially have a role that would
would involve sex determination so we
identified a short list of genes here so
you'll see in the short list there we
actually have these four tandem repeats
of air semically a cytokine response
regulator if you'll recall that is the
master regulator Gene Poplar and it's
showing up again from our analysis as
being a strong candidate for a sex
determination Gene if you Willow however
we see several other genes that might be
interesting as well so there's this
gata15 family transcription Factor this
is involved in the floral transition and
morphology in arabid offices we have a
zinc knuckle transmission Factor we have
a truncated Argonaut 4 Gene so Argonaut
4 is involved in the rddm halfway the
RNA dependent DNA methylation so it
could be responsible for this threefold
difference we see in methylation between
males and females and then also a few
hypothetical proteins
so he developed a short list but we know
only one or two of these are actually
going to be involved in sex so we really
need to to further narrow down this list
so our next step then was to refine our
sex determination hypothesis and
validate this using malicious photos
which represent a natural disruption of
the diocese system
so uh very rarely monicious Willows can
be found in nature and we have one such
individual in our collection can you
call 94003
so uh this one actually has separate
male and female flowers on the same cat
cake
um so it's monicious and uh we developed
an S1 and S2 family as well as a male
and female out reach region so we
crossed this monisha's parent to our
male Refuge genome and also to our
female and so we obtained these four
families that we used to look at the
inheritance of ownership
we also conducted alumina and packed bio
the sequencing of the minutiae's parent
which we use to annotate and assemble a
monicious reference sheets now we have a
malicious reference in addition to our
our pre-existing male and female
reference
we also conducted Illumina DNA and rnac
of some of the progeny from this
municious parent and from that we
identified the causal variant
responsible
so notably nominacious plants are
genotypically CW so if you will recall
females or CW emails or CC so it appears
that monicious moments are genotypically
female however their chromosome 15w has
this large 1.1 megabase deletion on it
and that deletion actually disrupts most
of these candidate sex termination genes
so the 15w English is missing error 17
and many of these others in fact Gata 15
is the only one of these that's still
present so that tells us a couple things
one if ar17 were a single Gene Master
radiator that is responsible for
switching to Sexes like it is in popular
its absence would mean that these plants
would be male that does not occur to be
the case uh and the fact that they get
these monies intermediates suggests that
uh it's likely a two Gene system
regulating sex in Willow especially we
have a partial disruption so we get this
this morning
and so this is what that uh monisha's
parent genome assembly looks like so
here is a Dot Plot this Compares
alignment between two genomes so where
you see a line or a DOT that's where
there is a similar sequence so on the
x-axis we have our our female reference
genome chromosome 15w and then on the
y-axis we have our contigs from our pack
bio assembly of our monicious parent so
in the middle here this track is
actually our chromosome 15w it was a
simple to do a single content which was
quite nice and then our chromosome 15z
and the minutius grant was assembled in
these two continents so you'll see where
you don't see mapping from the Z contigs
the sex extermination region it
highlighted the yellow here this is
actually that 1.1 megabase deletion so
we see that this region is not present
in any of our chromosome 15 objects from
the resist parent but it is in the in
our female reference so this large
deletion is disrupting uh nr17 but Gata
15 and the zooming model is canon in
genes that's still present and so that
tells us gatf15 might have a role in sex
change
so I mentioned we generated a cell to
now cross families from this monisha's
parent so because this one you just find
a ZW but this W has this large deletion
we we're choosing to call this W
chromosome a w superscript h such that
it results in malicious plants instead
of few so when we solve our zwh monishes
parent we would expect 25 of using male
15 is each emuation malicious project
and then 25 of homozygous wh
om now when we look at the S1 and the S2
families we see they're segregating for
roughly around two to three monishes to
one male and we also collected GBS or
sequencing data on every individual and
this has two family and we only saw ZZ
and zwh genotypes corresponding with
male and when you just respectively that
tells us that homozygous wh is actually
diesel so this large 1.1 megabase
deletion is probably disrupting genes
critical to function
in Plants such that
they don't survive
so to validate our hypothesis we
outcross our monisha's parent zwh to a
male ZZ and we got 50 monishes and 50
male production he has a quick start a
valid in this hypothesis that we
observed
now if these get a little more
interesting when we crossed our zwh
monisha's parents to a ZW female so we
saw about 25 male 25 lumicious but then
about over half the span was actually
female and among these females from our
our limited DNA restquencing we saw both
ZW and wwh
so that tells us that a normal W can
actually restore viability that uh is
lost when you have a wh
and so looking at that closer these are
igb plots of our Illuminati Navy
sequencing from that when we just biting
across so that family that we saw males
emails and malicious progeny and uh what
this is is the uh
this represents the relative amount of
reeds mapping her Locus to the reference
so at this top this is our our female
parent 15w reference at the bottom here
these are maps to our monicious Baron
pigeon wh records so in the mail see you
highlighted in blue we see they don't
really have much mapping to either
either the W or the wh chromosome which
makes sense because they are our CZ
genotypically
the monicious plants are highlighted
here in green they don't really have any
mapping to the female 15w but they do
have pretty good map into the monisha's
15wh confirming their zwh genotype and
then for the females we see all five
have mapping to the the regular
chromosome pitching Deputy from the
mother uh confirming that that
chromosome is necessary for for female
in his cross but when we look at uh
they're mapping to the 15 wh municious
reference you see one actually is pretty
good mapping and the other four do not
so that tells us that four of these are
ZW and this one individual here is
actually wwh confirming that that
genotype is is viable yeah
so I started off by showing you this
integrated genomics approach how we use
the biographics to identify Canada genes
and then how we refine this hypothesis
using malicious Willows But ultimately
what we need to do is functionally
validate our genes now unfortunately in
Willow no one has figured out how to
success and regenerate with those from
tissue
so we can't generate single transforms
so because of that we have to rely on a
heterologist system to
our Canon genes so we chose all of our
favorite bottle plants arabidopsis to
overexpress each of these candidates
exterminations
so we overexpressed using arabidopsis
and then we followed it up with floral
proteomic analysis
so I'm doing a floral proteomics we
could look at what genes what pathways
are perturbed when we express each of
our candidates sex termination genes
so this look here I show these are six
of the candidate sex variation genes
that we tested we also tested leafy and
cyanocus tea as control genes so these
are genes that we know are not involved
in sex determination per se in Willow
but they are involved in the soil
development Pathways and we know we
should be able to get uh
phenotypes from these when we express
we got around 426 uh independent events
for each of these each of these over
expressed genes and so uh We've checked
it anywhere from 11 000 to 16 000
proteins from each of these each of
these over expressions
and if you'll notice from the the total
differentiate budget proteins the SE are
proteins that have significant
differences between
the expression line
and control we see that three of them
have a very large number of
differentiate abundant proteins so Air
17 gha15 and then this hypothetical
protein all have over 4 000 different
differentially abundant proteins in
Floral tissue so that tells us that they
probably have some role in in Floral
expression and when we look at these
three only error 17 and gatf15 had
differentiated but in proteins that had
annotations involved directing the
formula
so we see from the independently that
ar-17 and gat18 are emerging from our
functional analysis as the two most
likely candidates to actually be
responsible for sex change
so I'll highlight the results from those
two in a bit more detail
so these are the results from our
expression of ar-17 in arabidopsis so uh
here is a volcano plot showing the the
abundance of proteins we detectives we
detected over 16 000 proteins of these
over 4 300 were differentially abundant
and among those are under proteins we
saw multiple genes that had adaptations
directly involved in the full
development many of which were annotated
as being involved in pollen antipino
development to Peter being the precursor
tissue for an African statements and
notably we see down regulation of many
of these male-fold development chains we
also see a down regulation of
pistolidate so epistle on it is a
b-class mask box shoe it is essential
for development of male formal tissue so
if you remember from one of the earlier
slides I showed you that in persimmon
um it is actually a down regulation
epistolon and that is response in the
pathway of converting from male to
female and actually in Poplar where
ar-17 is the signal gmaster Ray later
it's also thought to mediate the switch
somehow through generically and just a
lot and we see the same thing appears to
be happening in shrunk oil so taken
together
this tells us that with all these male
genes being down regulated that error 17
might have a role to suppress the nail
soil development
and this is consistent with what we see
in our malicious Villas where these four
copies of ar-17 are are absent and we
get male 4 development
now uh gntft was the other Gene that we
saw differentiate funded proteins that
were involved in silver
so we once again detected uh around 16
000 differential abundant proteins uh
nearly 6 000 or sorry about 16 000
proteins total nearly 6 000 of which
were differentiated by and this was the
most of any of the the genes we tested
and among those 6000 we're also multiple
sort of allergies uh particularly to
call your attention to these two ISO
forms of looting or rotunda 2 down here
so in arabidopsis when lunig is knocked
out that actually results in conversion
of uh sepals and petals to carpals as
well as the reduction in stamina
development so that tells us that you
know maybe down regulation of this Gene
which is what's happening it could be
responsible for improved carpal
development
uh moreover because g815 is a
transcription Factor we were able to use
dapseat to test its its binding enzymes
in the genome so how adapts it works
briefly is you express your
transcription factor in Nitro and then
you incubate that with genomic DNA so
that genomic DNA has the methylation
profile from whatever tissue it came
from so in our case we used female
floral DNA and male floral DNA so we
have the because we know that
methylation we I showed up on the
earlier side there's a huge difference
in methylation between males and females
so uh and so you you incubate your
treasury factor with your genomic DNA
you pull down uh DNA advantages Factor
sites and then you map those those reads
to your reference to get your data
transmission Factor binding
so here these are the consensus binding
sequences from female on our left and
male on the right
uh so you'll notice that there's very
high support for these these binding
sites they're pretty consistent between
the two between the female male
libraries and they're also consistent
with a gat class of transmission factor
which should bind to a ghea or similar
equity which is what we see here TG AGC
so that tells us that adapting active
was valid and we just found 150 Gene
Targets in the female library and only
28 in mail and among those Gene Targets
in the female Library were a couple of
floral development teams so one is ath1
which is a
um well homologous ath1 which Associates
with a game is that class C masmox Gene
involved in carbon
and the other Gene was a transfusion
factor involved in polar sensors so
together this suggests to us that g815
might have a role in promoting female
floor development and that's also
consistent what we see in our malicious
Willows where g8015 is the only
candidate sex termination Gene still
present in the humaceous Burrows
so that leads us to our refined model
for sex termination so we took this
integrative genomics and volumatics
approach to identify candidate genes we
refine those models in malicious with us
and then we did functional analysis to
confirm the role of HR candidate genes
and arrived at this model so notably we
think in settings for Korea sex mediated
by a 2G system such that it was loving
ar-17 and g815 such that ar-17 is
suppressed in airflow development while
Gata 15 is promoting female soul
and so what that what that looks like in
our model is uh males are at ZZ Gene
type they don't have a a sex
determination region so they result in
male flow of God we think this is the
sort of the default pathway for willow
when you have a ZW you have a w
chromosome so that has a gha15 that is
promoting female flow development it
also has those four copies of ar-17
which we think are suppressing milk or
at all based on our functional analysis
results so together uh you get female
captains now in Monisha solos which have
that largest addition on the 15w we
still have g815 promoting Pinos flow
development but we're missing those four
copies of ar-17 so we don't get the
simultaneous suppression of mail flow
about it and as a result we get male and
female flowers developing on the same
cat
what's notable about this system is it
is distinct from the single Gene system
in popular which is mediated by error 17
where that single Gene alone is kind of
mediate this switch
so now shifting gears a little bit from
the sex termination story I want to talk
a bit about a couple other projects I
did in my research also in conjunction
with overcast
spring so the first involves the
assembly and annotation of 11 struggle
the genomics now in the Cornell struggle
the reading program we utilize a variety
of short-looked species to develop
cultivars so with a uh it's readily able
to intercross between species
now up until this point we were really
relying on two reference genetics which
are actually shown here at the top of
this table so uh non-porosis which is
the settings for period female and Fish
Creek which is a sandix for Korean male
and there's also the sun of 9.6 so we
had a male female reference we were
really relying on and most of the
analysis I presented prior to this uh
involved back into the 9406 you know
Revenue Channel but of course we wanted
to characterize uh we wanted to sequence
genome between other species uh so we
could uh do some so comparative genomics
and add these two with sort of our as a
resource for our program so we selected
uh 11 individuals across six species so
say for Korea acidic situences integral
accordionis and udensis I actually have
uh most of those displayed here so you
can see some of the some of the
diversity across the the shrug Withers
uh that were collected here
so
uh we did Nano for sequencing those are
then scaffolded with high C and then uh
alumina sequencing is used to polish
those those assembles
alumina nanopore and rnac were also
collected uh sorry Illumina and nanopore
rnac were collected from each of these
individuals as well from eight tissue
types which we use to annotate these
reference tabs so this table here shows
some of those the genome assembly
statistics
um and so I the top two here I have are
our
prior to genomes as a comparison and we
see that our booster score is above 95
for all of these genomes suggesting that
they are pretty good ascendants
now if we look at The annotation uh we
can see that we're getting around uh
usually between 30 and 31 000 genes
annotated per genome this is a little
less than the about 34 000 we expect in
our from our previous references however
this is probably due to the fact that we
did not collect floral rna-seq or rnac
from stress tissues in these individuals
so we missed out on a lot of the genes
that are expresses those very specific
context nevertheless uh you know these
are are pretty substantial genomes and
annotations and they really add a lot to
the uh the original genomic resources
notably this is the first time anyone
has assembled an Integra orionagi or new
genesis Geo which we now have available
and I should also mention that a
previous question in our lab Justin
Wilkerson did a lot of work actually
making crosses between each and these
families and developing genetic linkage
Maps so we have a lot of other uh
General resources as well on these
particular individuals we're sort of now
form a nice nice core a core set that we
can use for future studies question
now in looking at these genomes as you
know right now probably I'm really
interested in sex determination so I
wanted to see what does the gene copy
number of these candidate sex
termination genes look like between
different genomes
um and so these are all these are our
feature extraocular species they all
have been confirmed about the chromosome
15zw sex termination system so we expect
to go into this that we would say the
same gene content across this
explanation
we found out however that that does not
appear to be the case so I have error 17
and gata15 are two strongest candidates
streams highlighted here remember error
17 is our predicted suppressor of
malfunction MGA t850 is our predicted
promoter or female function so from
these we see that
both of these are present in preparing
and situences females and absent from
males however gha15 is actually absent
from our saved Instagram email and then
ar-17 is absent from the viminalis and
choreography females as a gag
so uh we see one or two of our or of our
attendance explanation genes are not
present in some of these other species
which was very puzzling to us and that
tells us that even though these have the
same Locus and the same chromosome
involves extermination that they
probably have a different gene or set of
genes or greatly insects and it's quite
interesting and really sort of
underscores how Dynamic the sex crisis
are within this genus and some more
reviews be done in the future to uh to
confirm that and to validate what are
the actual candidate Master regulatory
genes in some of these other species
like Statics
another interesting finding from the
study was uh this Integra female p336 we
found early in our reading program that
it appears that all the Prodigy
developed from this this parent or
female so so to test that we crossed
p336 with as many male reference
students as we have so we crossed it
with 9401 and Fish Creek these are our
male papuria we crossed it with 943
that's been monicious so the one with
the weird disruptive sex chromosome and
across the situences with coronagi and a
few dense so six male parents across
four different species and in all cases
so we we had over 200 progeny uh most of
them were flowering and in all cases we
saw 100 female crush regardless of the
male parent which was was quite
fascinating right you know that's not
normal to have and I'll email
dinner time so we'll work out really
interesting about it so when we looked
at the next generation of projects so we
took NF1 from this this integral by
suture lenses cross and then we back
crossed that back where since you want
to distributed that cross file and also
outcrossed it with 941 acid extra
Courier to create a three-way cross and
in both cases once again 100 of the
production Works email this is after a
second generation so you know that was
very interesting to us right and so our
hypothesis of what might be immediated
is is that it could be a cytopositely
inherited Factor so if you'll recall
chloroplasts and mitochondria have their
own genomes they're also only inherited
internally so only only the female
parent can pass on it's not a cons build
and chloroplast genome so we predicted
that
um if there were some factor in either
profession that were inherited to female
that were resulting in all-female
progeny that might explain this
inheritance so when we looked at our our
genome assemblies in the mitochondrial
genomes we notice that this rpl-10
homolog is missing from the mitochondria
in p236 now rpl-10 is a highly concerned
it's all plant tax savings meaning prior
fights and gymnosperms so it's highly
conserved and we see in our other Willow
genomes so the fact that it's missing is
is quite interesting and definitely not
expected moreover RPO 10 is actually
just very high levels of expression in
pollen in arabidopsis and a couple other
species
so taking together this emerges as our
most likely candidate right now uh for
for being responsible for this
all-female inheritance across multiple
Generations now we still need to
functionally validate it but um yeah
this is a very a very unusual uh
inheritance technique that was that
we're able to elucidate with some of
these uh some of these things
so now I want to finish off the talk by
talking about another project I did this
spring at Oak Ridge where we looked at
developing photoplasts for uh transient
over expression and crispr knockout in
trouble so as I mentioned earlier we
cannot generate stable transformance in
Willow many people have tried many
people have failed and so because of
that our functional genomics resources
or struggle though are quite limited
indeed many times you have to the the
annotations in these genomes are
actually based on their homology to
popular rabbit offices and with our our
testing our candidates activation genes
we had to use a rapid offices the
hydrologic system contestants so I
wanted to see if we could potentially
use protoplasts as it means to do some
in-view of functional studies in a short
level
so we took two-week-old cabins so
Willow's very easy to populate from
Greenwood cuttings we took young leaves
these arrows point two two kinds of or
took these Leaf cuttings and then used
these to isolate these protoplasts which
are shown here
so we obtained very high yields from
these young soil grown leaves and that
alone is very interesting because in
popular and many other species you have
to use tissue culture grown leaves to
obtain total loss and Willow we can get
very high yields just from these
silicone leaves which are incredibly
easy to generate so already Willow is
emerging has a very robust system for
protoplast assets more robust than even
popular
so we were able to uh Express four
different fluorescent reporter proteins
so uh in panel a this is an egfp panel B
this is super folding GMP panel C is
jpuv and has this faint signal which is
actually what you'd expect from the
community construct and then panel D is
M Cherry so all four of these Plus have
reported proteins we're able to
translate into work stress we obtained
fairly High uh transfection rates and
um and expression rates so that shows us
that that Transit expression is viable
and it works quite well in a helicopter
class also this is the first time anyone
has shown Chinese expression uh in
willowbrose classes
um so so we showed we could isolate
protocols effectively we show we could
do transient over expression so our next
step was to see if we could uh
accomplish Gene editing and struggle
those cells so we did is we selected
three different single copy genes from
the willow genome gustafolia
phytochromate and frigida are then
designed to two guide rnas to Target the
first Exon of each of these genes so
that's shown here in this cartoon uh
these red bars are the target sides we
just got our X
and so we did applicant sequencing on
those protoplasts and those results are
shown here so this this Top Line on each
each set is the wild type sequence and
we have each of the other sequences we
detected and the number of apricons of
those and then highlighted in red is the
pan sequence probably space share
adjacent proteins uh where the guide RNA
targets so they can see either
substitutions or one or several base
character deletions immediately adjacent
to the parasite for all of these
suggesting to us that these are in fact
crispr edits that uh casanine and is
working and the god rnas are targeted in
the middle of genome
uh and notably for Augusta Folia our
Target sites were close enough to each
other that our applicants were able to
span the distance between both of them
and we were able to detect a multiplex
so in this case we see we see cuts out
at both guide RNA sites resulting in a
90 to 100 base pair deletion from these
genes Sam tells us that not only is is
Christopher working with it but we can
accomplish multiple
people and so so when we think about how
now we have transient over expression
well established at crispr knockout
established it really opens up a whole
new level of possibilities for
Congressman showings in Willow we can
think about applications now where we
might be able to knock out or over
Express a gene in Wheel of protoplast
and then do single cell sequencing to
look at at in vimo expression
differences which we haven't had to do
in just below at all in the past or we
can think about things like bimolecular
Reflections complementation where we
look at
approaching co-localization in global
cells and these can now be done in
Willow cells with Willow genes for the
first time
so to summarize uh some of the results
so we did differential expression eqtl
analysis to identify candidate sex
termination genes we used monisha's
Willows crosses and sequencing to refine
our hypothesis then
uh we
did functional analysis on our candid
genes using expression in rabidopsis and
then job seeking we conducted whole
genome assembly annotation of 11
troubled species and found that the sex
termination system likely differs
between related species and then lastly
we demonstrated that protoplasts are a
viable system for functional genomic
studies in in below and we now have this
this industry
so with that I'd like to acknowledge all
the people who've helped with
past five years there are too many to
put on the slide here but you know all
the members of the spot lab some of whom
are listed here
all the people I work with at Oakridge
National Laboratory this spring they
were instrumental in actually the last
three of these chapters I presented uh
they had some role or not so uh Jerry
tuske and Jay Chen xiaohan
of headache in particular and then of
course my committee all of them are here
in this room
um and then my funding sources over the
years so an NSF grant that Larry
received that supported my research my
first couple years the USD and IFA
Fellowship which has supported my
research since last two years and then
the Dua sdgsr Fellowship which provided
the funding for me to actually go to
overage and receive a lot of the
specialized training that that
substantially Advanced my location
process
so with that I'd like to open it up for
any questions
thanks Brandon uh we're going to start
with questions online so if you're on
Zoom feel free to unmute and ask your
question
and so that actually two questions
what is the gene specific I mean tissue
specific expression pattern in of ARL 17
inguinal
and the second one is um
the arabatoposis arr17
deletion line is there any email type
like a flower organ
differences
right okay so I think there's two
questions there one is what is the
tissue specific
Gene and the other one was what does the
arabidosis air 17 knockout Rover
especially like
so for um for the tissue specific
expression and shrugolo error 17 is
highly expressed in female catkins one
thing I didn't mention is that there are
also a couple
autosomal copies of that Gene that are
present in males and emails that show a
low level of expression in both captains
however we see a much higher expression
rate in females presumably from those
four copies in the SDR there are low
levels of ar-17 expression in in some of
the other tissue types but it's it's
it's quite minimal prepared to what we
see so I would say it's primarily
cadmium expressed now as far as what
does it around adopsis mutant phenotype
look like oh when I was looking at the
existing literature I could not find any
um well they have generated Air 17
Knockouts they did not really generate
uh substantial phenotype from what I
gathered
um so they're they're thought to me
involve this out of kind of signaling
but they're certainly not uh critical or
they might have redundancy within the
arabidopsis
thank you
other questions online
I have a question
um I have two questions actually
um Brennan first of all good job on the
presentation in the seminar and an
amazing amount of work so
congratulations on that
um I had a question on the eqtl circus
diagram what's going on on chromosome 4
on the eqtl ring it seems like there's a
disproportionate change in
yes
um right there at the bottom right
so which which chromosome chromosome
four right okay yeah there's a huge
number of eqtls yeah
yeah we don't really know
um like I said one could spend a better
part of her career looking at all of the
weird things that we see in this
um so I you know again I was really
focused on on sexual business sex
termination
um so we we need to go and look at that
more closely I don't know what's going
on there yeah but you spend like half an
hour looking at this you can find all
these weird little things like oh what's
going on there
sure
it's always nice to have more work to do
right and then I had a philosophical
question you know
um with the consistency of daishi in the
salacacier family
it's really surprising that there's so
much differentiation and diversity in
the mechanisms of sex determination
chromosomes vary ZW versus X Y Etc so
give me a hypothesis or a philosophical
explanation for why it's so tightly
controlled
um in terms of daishi but why the
mechanisms vary so much
over the answer
um one sort of hypothesis is that so
there is obviously a a fitness advantage
to be indicious inside Casey right
that's why we see it
um that could be because
um
trades intersectionally antagonistic so
uh where presence in one sex is
detrimental acrossed into the other sex
is beneficial so we could think of
things like secondary metabolites in in
catkins as an example right so these can
increase pollinator attraction but they
can also increase pest attraction as
well
um so that's one example
um also you know second of it highlights
take a lot of resources to produce so
they might not be beneficial to have in
both sexes
um as far as why has the the Str shifted
locations and heterogeneous systems
um in order you know the general model
for how that could happen is is if
another Locus somehow becomes or there's
a selection towards another Locus
because it confers off some some sort of
Advantage right so we could think about
if we think about like the system
mistakes but period where we think it's
Error 17 and GHA team I would
hypothesize that you know ar-17 at some
point translocated
um to chromosome 15 and by being linked
with Gata 15 that was advantageous in
the ancestor of Santa Korea and so that
took over as being the primary Locus for
for sex termination if that makes sense
very good thank you
yeah Jerry you just stole Steve's main
question so
sorry about that
any other questions online
okay if you have a question uh raise
your hand and we'll come back to you but
I'm going to turn to the room here
except for his committee members
additional questions it's your last
chance with Brennan
yes
um Frederick can you tell us about the
spirit
three times for the uh always impression
line for the two kind I think you tried
more than uh
more than five right what are the
phenotypes different kind of genes so
the question was with the arabidopsis
expression lines what were the
phenotypes here
um so as you mentioned we detected about
four to six when we obtained four to six
events per Gene uh the reason we looked
at proteomics was because even going
into this we did not expect to see the
floral differences in Floral development
and if we didn't have the resources to
build and and dissect all these tiny
rapidoxious flowers and look at the the
carbon counts so from the start we chose
to look at
proteomics
um because we didn't expect to see any
noticeable differences and indeed in
terms of plural morphology we did not
the only um kind of anecdotal you know
typic difference that I observed was the
Gata 15 that's that our predicted female
promoter Gene it's
over expression uh arabidopsis lines it
seem to have really poor growth we had a
really hard time even obtaining enough
enough plants to to test
um that could just be a coincidence or
it could be a result of overexpression
we can't really include that but that's
the only
um
the other phenotype I'll mentioned is we
overexpressed fire and notice t as a
Control G and those arabidopsis showed
very early flowering phenotypes which is
consistent with around
is only like 36 000 genes you have 24
000 deg it's just on that signs I mean
between me and male flowers
so that's a lot of ggs right oh so
you're saying you were surprised that
there are 24 000 different Chief
Expressions so I will add that that is
genes and alternative transcripts
um but still it is a is a large number
but again if you look at let's go back
to the captain dictionary
you look at female and male catkins
right there's a lot of morphological
differences between
them so it's not entirely surprising
that we see widespread difficult to come
along that much less sorry the long ddgs
is much less than geds between these two
different kinds of flowers
yeah
I think we detected around 36 000 totals
which uses alternative transcripts and
24 000 of those about 230 different
sheets now
so the whole genome is about 35 000
genes it's about 57 000 genes and
alternative transcripts so we looked at
the transcript level
um so yeah about 50 000 55 57 000
transcripts 36 000 of those were
expressed
um 24 000 were differentially expressed
now I'll also add that our sample size
was huge
so I are we were able to detect even
small differences in expression or
significance
of a very large data set yeah
is that a Willow and the popular are so
Seminar can
you tell me the genuine popular so yeah
you bring up a good point so the
question was can you uh transformation
of archanging and popularity uh short
answer is yes uh transformation systems
have been well established and popular
however the challenge behind that is we
want floral phenotypes right and if
Halper is a tree the generation time is
several years so
um you know one can imagine this it's
not very feasible in a PhD timeline
um so in terms of resources and you know
time frame around us which is really the
most viable option
okay so I have one more question
yeah uh so you know I mean
oxen and cytokine and they usually uh
work and technology so I wonder if you
test I mean the what happened if you
externally uh applied oxen to the
flowers what could happen
right so you bring up a really good
question so one sort of Pilots deviated
a few years ago because I took
um
plural shoots before the catkins emerge
and actually apply I think oxen cytokine
and gibralic acid and I think ethafone
today I want to see if if any of these
hormone treatments would would change
the development and it didn't work and
we didn't really see any any differences
um so you know
we would have to test at different
developmental time points right but at
least our preliminary Nursery did not
include promising results we chose not
to pursue that further
I would add that the challenging point
there is when sex is determined in
Willow and you have to apply that
treatment at the time that sex is
determined and it's very difficult to
to understand exactly when sex is
determined during blood formation
uh several months before the captains
actually emerged
right so yeah so four of us are set in
the summer so low as far in the spring
four of those are set to some of the
floor and I think I would say New York
being are able to see like
histologically the the difference in
male and female in around August
but that's when you can actually observe
it so it's obviously been initiated
before that and it's going to vary based
on requirements see
excellent question
any more questions
yeah yeah
um so just from like a bioenergy biomass
perspective do you see like uh
differences between males and females
how about where they're growing yeah so
um in terms of qualitative differences
um
a previous grad student Fred broker did
do some work on the
um some quantitative traits so things
like Crown diameter
um do appear to differ somewhat and also
I think Russ's susceptibility maybe a
little also
differ a little like quantitative and
chromosomes
um it's awesome that you can go and look
at this and we'll be like oh that's uh
you know a thousand wide ground it's if
you know you can't but so there are some
quantitative differences they do if I
don't SEO but they are small
so the good news is that Brennan will be
staying here in Geneva uh he will be
he's getting grilled by his Future boss
Tyler here uh so he will be staying on
the postdoc and switching to work um
uh we will look forward to continuing to
see and work with Brennan but for now
please join me in thanking Brennan for a
great seminar and this brings
defense-a-thon to your Club
foreign
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu